i'm jay seville ski has a company in
north-east poland just a few kilometers
away from the border to russia it's a
family-run enterprise with a workforce
of eight the factory a converted barn
turns out wooden soles for the shoe
industry as customers are in germany and
scandinavia
business is good but it could be better
with lower labor costs which is why the
boss wants to set up a new production
center in neighboring Russia but the
authorities across the border made it
immediately clear that polish businesses
are not welcome the Russian officials
were against be investing there the
regular people were friendly but the
authorities weren't playing ball that's
despite trade restrictions having been
relaxed three years ago between the
Masuria region of Northeast Poland and
the Russian enclave of Kaliningrad
residents on both sides of the border
have special visas for the other country
almost all of my friends and neighbors
go over to Russia to buy cheap
cigarettes and gasoline although I don't
Braun yevo is eight kilometers away from
the border to Kaliningrad it's a small
town with a population of around 10,000
but a big shopping hub with a plethora
of supermarkets they thrive on demand
from Russian customers Russian shoppers
are permitted to take up to 500 euros
worth of goods back across the border
each day demand for certain goods has
increased since the Western sanctions
were imposed on Russia everyone comes
here there's a better range and it's
cheaper I bought myself some shoes over
half the shoppers in this supermarket
come from the Kaliningrad region
top of many shopping lists are dairy
products and sausages from the EU items
no longer available back home in Russia
due to the sanctions
well there's no more cheese from Europe
so I bought some polish camembert
everything's more expensive in Russia
and poorer quality too for us cheese as
a delicacy we continue our journey up to
the coast just a year ago the area was
swarming with Russian tourists on and
off season the back custom has plummeted
since the crisis in Ukraine
Alexandra Baron Chavez has seen turnover
at the restaurant she runs reduced by
more than half the remaining trickle of
Russian customers has left locals
lunching among themselves again you just
don't see Russian visitors anymore
I count on one hand our last Russian
customers the local Porsche dealership
had been enjoying good business with
cross-border car buyers to cater to
demand from Kaliningrad the manager even
recruited russian-speaking staff
since the Ukraine crisis erupted earlier
this year though the inflow of Russians
looking to buy luxury goods from the
West has flagged and that slump in
business has also been affecting the
dealerships biggest source of turnover
repair and maintenance services the head
of the dealership hopes that crucial
business from the east will return
sooner or later
both Polish and Russian customers they
expect the highest quality they can get
and this is actually what they are here
for and that's what's in common between
Polish and Russian customers so we are
trying to stay away from the politics
and just to focus on our job back to the
shoe sole manufacturer where the manager
is determined to pursue his expansion
plans in Kaliningrad he's waiting for a
resolution of the Ukraine crisis and an
improvement in the investment climate in
Russia
you